foreign
yes that was yesterday right
so we're not going to ask you any
questions right now but just
just aware of what's going on you have
the right to remain silent anything you
say can it will be used against you in a
court of law
you have the right to an attorney if you
can't afford one one will be appointed
to you you have the right to have that
attorney president at any time during
questioning and you have the right to
refuse to answer any of our questions
okay somebody else is gonna have to do
that for you ma'am
okay
you said you didn't do that what am I
talking about
now
so who did that
if it wasn't you
I guess
when I was there
I stayed at my house and my parents
found me I know his apartment has got
your own thoughts
we drove by myself
what morning
yeah okay she she was at the house
yesterday and it wasn't like that
yesterday
thank you
are bad
are you serious yes
I don't understand that but you should
have asked questions yesterday when it
was served and he asked if you had any
questions
why would I destroy my own stuff that's
a good question I've been wondering the
same thing do you not think she's lying
she has an order of protection
three times
I've not done anything to him okay look
I'm not the judge jury an executioner
I'm just the arresting officer
but um
if you understand that then why are you
so angry about this
but you were told you had a warrant and
you didn't do anything about it that's
it okay
I know you're a heroin user do you use
needles no so you have no needles on you
right now
will you check his belt line really good
absolutely
I said turn and face the car I didn't
tell you to move no
no too
thank you
foreign